So let's say you found a font
that looks great on a bunch of
different screen resolutions and
different sizes, and even better,
it doesn't detract from
the overall theme of your app.
How would you use it?
So here's a small app that I
did to show you the different
typographical sizes that are available
in Android and their names.
Now, right now they're all
using the Roboto font.
Let's go and change that.
So here's the app that
we were just looking at.
So if you want to add your own font,
the first thing that you will need to do
is add an assets directory
under source main.
And we've included our font,
which is Courgette-Regular.
It was just a font that I
found on Google web fonts,
because most of them are available
with open source licenses.
So if we switch over to the Android
view, it will show up as assets and
resurrectory.
But those are the same location,
so you might see one or
the other depending on how you
set up your Android Studio.
If you're using your font inside
a fragment, due to the fragment life
cycle, you need to instantiate
the type face in the onAttach method.
The reason for
this is there's a short period of time
after a fragment is created, but
before it's attached to a host activity.
So, if you can see in this
Typeface.createFromAsset function,
we have getActivity and then getAssets.
If this is called before it's
attached to the activity,
it will result in an error.
So, if we go to our onCreate method,
after instantiating our text views,
we just call the setTypeface function
with the object that we just created.
So if we look at this on a device,
we can see that our display4 and
our headlineView have changed.
So this is our display4 here, and
then if we scroll up a bit,
right here is our headline.